the very last scene of the last Jedi
garnered gasps from packed theaters
across the globe
yep that little boy used the force to
guide a broom into his hand before
pausing from his work to stare into
space daydreaming about the resistance
who is that little boy and what exactly
did that mean and more importantly what
does the scene mean for the future of
Star Wars let's break down what could
potentially be the most important scene
in the last Jedi and be forewarned there
are more spoilers ahead he's a slave to
provide a little refresher one of the
last Jedi's plots sees fin and Rose
traveling to the planet can't annika to
find a hacker in the city of Kanto bite
the casino city more Monaco than Las
Vegas is the ultimate hangout for the
wealthy but that doesn't tell the whole
story as ROS points out drawing on her
own painful past the people working in
Kanto bite are slaves it's during this
sequence that we first encountered the
boy in one of the stables as Finn and
ROS escape he's among the child slaves
that clean and sleep in the stables
while caring for the fathers the space
ponies who end up serving as Finn and
Rosa's way out we know his name the star
wars the last Jedi visual dictionary
tells us that the boys named tamiri
black and according to IMDB first timer
- Merlin Blythe portrays the boy clearly
blag is at the least force sensitive and
that's nothing to scoff at in the Star
Wars universe in fact over the course of
the current trilogy he's one of only a
handful of people we've seen use the
Force a list that includes heavy hitters
like Luke Rey Leia kylo Ren Snoke in do
de in other words he's probably a big
deal he's a nobody
aside from offering up some of the
coolest space battles and most exciting
action sequences in the franchise the
last Jedi put a lot of effort into
shaking up the Star Wars mythology which
is another way of saying that a lot of
what we thought we knew about the saga
just went out like trash from a Star
Destroyer Rey the powerful force
sensitive hero of the new trilogy turns
out not to be the secret offspring of
one of the stories heavy hitters in fact
her parents were basically space trash
in the new Star Wars universe you don't
have to be a Skywalker or a Kenobi to be
important
along those lines - Miri black doesn't
appear to be related to anyone you've
heard of his parents abandon him just as
Rey's parents left her as the Skywalker
saga comes to a close we're learning
that anyone can be force sensitive from
a daughter of drunkards to a slave boy
who sweeps up father skat he won't be a
Jedi kylo Ren spelled out the new plan
for the movies going forward no more
Jedi
no more Sith tamiri blag is force
sensitive and he might do something with
it
but he won't be a Jedi because the order
as it existed is gone ray isn't one at
least as it's been traditionally defined
so as far as we know there aren't any
Jedi left to teach him and yes the Jedi
sacred books survived stowed away by Rey
on the Millennium Falcon but studying
from a book is very different from the
master Padawan dynamic built up over
generations of Jedi he could be a new
hope as Luke vowed before becoming one
with the force in the final act he won't
be the last Jedi but what it means to be
one and who gets to carry that mantle
going forward is wide open it likely
wasn't a coincidence that the last Jedi
ended with flags staring off into a star
cluster uncertain of his future just as
Luke did at the end of the Empire
Strikes Back
you could make the case that black is
the new Luke without the pedigree and
without the promise of proper Jedi
training or maybe he isn't then again
the odds of to marry black being the
only other force sensitive character
besides Rey in the galaxy far far away
is pretty slim and that also plays into
the new Star Wars Canon lag won't be the
only one there will be others maybe he
never makes it off can't Hanukkah maybe
he doesn't pop up in episode 9 both of
those scenarios would fit into what Star
Wars is now a brand new series where
anyone can use the Force and the Sith
and Jedi as we knew them or know more
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]